welcome to this video on playing a
15-minute game against mm Gil I'm not
sure how I should pronounce that
yeah it's a in English opening with c4
mm yeah no I have a choice I can go for
c5 or I can go for a 5 very fundamental
choice mm what you know the symmetrical
is of course very solid but also
somewhat boring at times so if there's
something something else entirely
yeah maybe I want to try something here
and the symmetrical I have an
interesting idea in this line let's see
what he's doing
of course depends on on white a bit
aha okay he's going for you form yeah
most players call Knight f3 it's it's a
bit of a decision of taste it's not
really a case of of movement quality
okay let's see okay let's let's try
something play for a quick b5
yeah well b5 as a pawn SEC sometimes as
possible it's not it's not entirely
ridiculous but I'm not sure that it is
really playable here you know rather
prepare that
now what white sometimes decides to just
play a form to stop b5 all together it
looks a bit ugly a form because of the
wholesome before in deform the so kind
of a Swiss cheese formation but it's not
really it's not really a problem you
quite often witness this kind of setup
with colors reversed where black is
playing see 585 against the English and
here white is a tempo up on that which
probably is not enough form for a real
advantage but it's certainly very solid
setup okay here's some not preventing b5
so I'm I'm going to play that of course
this is positionally desirable
achievement to have played b5 but it's
also a bit slow in terms of King site
development I must be M must be cautious
that I'm not falling too far behind and
development it is a closed position so
it's not like he's crudely meeting me on
f7 but still the position might might
open up and then my king is only aid so
the main thing the main thing to decide
now is if I should play Knight to f6 or
Knight to e7 after after a 6 like E 697
hmm I'm not I'm not sure about that
really I can also think about just to
take on seafoam
hmm that's not really clear to me I
probably I probably need to play d6
anyway so I'm going to do that now and
decide on the knight placement later on
e6 I wasn't so sure about Bishop e3 what
what am I doing with them
the c5 pawn it's always a possibility if
I'm to play d3 d4 then I'd like to play
but these six actually because it's
always tempting to have this long
diagonal open on Knight f6 there's also
the possibility for him to play a for
threatening a 5 mm nobody 697 that is so
it's a bit slow
yes six Bishop III I can go 94 I don't
like this the slow development too much
okay what else is there I can take and
and then decide on on the setup and
habits AB it's a bit early to to release
the tension down okay let's do that
now f6 has some one advantage over 97 it
it gets Knight g4 into the picture so he
probably cannot play Bishop III him
because of Nigeria
this is just just a bit a bit too
annoying and smooth yeah exactly
this is why he plays h3 so let's cancel
now a date 3 is a good multi-purpose
move anyway as g4 is part of whites
general expansion like a 4G phone okay
so here okay yeah here there might be a
situation but so it's a technical thing
if you if you think about his next movie
we'll play Queen d2 we are probably and
one possible tactical trick is takes on
c4 BC 95 attacking the pawn b3 and
Bishop h3 with the Knight f3 fork I hope
you could follow this line
the thing is I'm going to play here am I
going to do that now I guess I'm I guess
I am but wait wait wait wait maybe maybe
I have some some better move
it's not so clear what the bishop is
doing on on d7 really yeah what exactly
is it doing on d7 maybe a mirror it's
maybe not so bad
I think Wendy too is not not really
possible now due to the mentioned
tactical idea take 695 b3 bishop h3 the
only possible way to fuel it is f4 f4
Bishop g2 FV 5 bishop f1 takes on f6
mm-hmm this even this is even good for
me I'll be three bishop hmm f4 Bishop g2
F eat 5f one takes of six takes in two
takes to seven at the end I am material
down
really this is not working that's
disappointing
okay okay he's doing something else
internally playing for a forum yeah so
let's see how to continue now
he does not have a direct threat but he
might expand on the on the kingside even
more okay
fYI I underestimated a bit what am i
doing now I was I was also thinking that
before might be an idea as the night
does not have so I can go to d5 okay I
want to have an open file and it's open
to be found it's not clear what what
this piece on d7 is doing now
maybe I should should get a to c6 son
maybe even Knight a5 and Bishop c6 the
knight is not brilliant on a5 that's
that's clear but maybe I need to to to
get this Bishop to c6 it also lost 97
yeah yeah let's a bit ugly but still I
need I don't I think I need this
regrouping Bishop to c6 I can always put
the bishop back on a eight or something
I put the knight back on c6 but I need
to get some space for my knight on f6 as
well maybe can play e5 nah yeah but I
have 98 no it's not really that's not
really too threatening
yeah this was the idea so that I have a
possible 97 in case he goes for g4g 5
for example and they also have some
pressure on on Stoney form
so what are my next moves maybe right 97
controlling the e5 maybe Bishop back to
a 896 yeah the bad thing about 95 is
that the a pawn is not mobile a 5 a 4
would be a natural plan but I don't
think I had the time for that
yes I think something along 97 be sure
back to a eight nine to c6 probably back
than a five this is the way to go some
it's not so easy white will probably
play on the King yeah exactly play on
the King side and then play take some
more force in character where I am don't
need to vary so much about them and a
direct active plan but I can simply play
play defense against his advance and
look for counter chances against that I
not necessarily need to do something
drastic on my own having a flexible
defensive position is perfectly okay you
know I need to get the knight back into
play of course this is just not a good
piece the question is however is it
Bishop to a the knight c6 or should I
just drop it to b7
I know um b7 that's also stupid-looking
hmm I thought maybe a queen move Knight
B 78 to e6 or something but it's very
slow yeah that's too slow even that's
too slow
no probably probably dropping it back to
a a to the bishop and then 96 is the
best way to go he's taking lots of time
here I think I would have played the
move like Queen d2 by now he cannot play
Knight g3 for example at c3 is hanging
so I don't see any great direct
alternative to to Queen d2 just looks
like an harmonious move not sure what
else he should do I mean he could play
the pawn move like g5 or f5 but f5 okay
aha
so he wants to swing the Queen over here
yeah that's not bad but some that's a
viable idea okay let's not waste so much
time here I'm ahead on the clock so
better try to keep it that way I have a
rather flexible defensive position
anyway they don't see him yeah I'm aging
bit quickly but it's just not happening
I if I go back to c6 I also have this 94
idea
No yeah yeah I'm not sure I mean he does
not have a great obvious plan here yeah
this is this is logical
after three new one yeah okay
ninety-four but maybe maybe he should
try two together deform like you oh that
is surprising yeah I didn't I didn't
really expect that move
it gives up the dark squares but okay he
suddenly wants to have some play does
not want to sit and wait all the time
this is of course understandable who
came let's let's go to the forum
this was the idea anyway there's no
reason to not do that now I don't have a
concrete threat though at least I don't
see it if there is one
if you place a move like let's say what
would be to d1 what is my reply I mean
maybe I can just take it only to end and
play something like maybe a 5 even if
I've he's an ST it's not in a position
to answer with a form with a form sorry
oh yeah now we have the this is now in a
completely different situation after
he's giving up his dark squared bishop
the dark squares now are the problem
this is really surprising he also does
not have a great square where does he go
I mean 95 there's more than one problem
with that move one one one issue is I
can play ecigs just expelling it and -
where's right going it does not have a
great square oh I can just I can just
just take it I mean it's not bad at all
my bishop takes d4 I think it's a
mistake it gives up this all-important
bishop okay well 95 is the move that is
the most likely follow up now you six or
Bishop takes yeah I like okay yeah many
surprising moves now
yeah that'sthat's not that's not clear
now what what is the best way to go
Bishop maybe maybe Bishop c6m attacking
that and like night b2 and queen 85
checking a2 and so on
not bad not bad at all yeah okay let's
do that and just try to try to play
quickly keep the edge on the clock so
Queen a 5 p.m. just attacking I don't
really see a big counter play coming he
cannot allow Queen takes a to relief at
least I don't see it how it should be
possible after that b3 is almost gone as
well
maybe he needs to be creative somehow
make a second out of it yes that's them
that's the passive way to play it may be
necessary maybe okay how to do that now
maybe 95 years
22 was also possibility attending Quincy
to Quincy 3 is also not bad yeah but ok
the night ISS is good on c5 answer at
the tax reform and it makes a subsequent
Queenie invasion stronger move like
Quincy 3 Queen d2 is strengthened by the
night I just look someone shaking the
Queen here hmm should be 5 is going
queen of - yeah
hmm
many many interesting moves now
Quincy 322 they they all look Kara
they all look dangerous 23 if he takes
pawn takes Knight d3c 2 wins the
exchange that's not not too bad and
Queen d2
isn't this just just good I mean yeah
maybe queen f2 it's not it's not winning
instantly okay
I mean this is not bad if I win the
exchange I have a 5a for coming
I don't know I hope I'm not selling this
this is too cheaply I didn't expect that
I thought that Queen c2 but he has got
its got rugby to on that
hmm Jeff then this wasn't the best
probably rugby to silly stuff but it's
right so it's a move Quincey to look B
to wear and a five possibly blunders the
Queen that's disappointing really yeah
and this was a very bad operation Queen
C 3
preparing a 584 yeah what can you do
he's intending to play of six now okay
he can take and play of six but I don't
think it's it's so dangerous
you can try Queen - Queen age four and
so on but from from a strategical point
of view if 6 is also a weak phone yeah
if he had to through college for
something but how to get there my next
moves on look here and Queen the eight
or Queen d6 attacking the pawn and then
it's I hope she needs to need to retreat
unfortunately I don't really see how to
make any progress
I hear h6 I can play h6 to to get get
this route g8 mobile again okay so this
is this is safe now I can try to try to
get the pawn now mark and I'll not take
it don't see why not
okay
I can also just take you for why not
actually 50 seconds of Liam they could
have taken me five didn't didn't see
that okay I know everything's think back
okay let's oh my it's a check on a five
that's unfortunate
check fa2 was check no time warning
check
that's g1 checkmate yeah it got down to
a couple of seconds at the end and yeah
this was very complicated
yeah here he is around here is the the
critical phase of this game the capture
is a pretty big positional mistake but I
didn't really punish it to the fullest
here yeah here there must be something
something else between c3 I really
underestimated 93 yeah the computer has
a good suggestion which I didn't see
okay of course this I saw but him here I
didn't continue to calculate yeah okay
there's this idea computer move but this
I'm not so sure about I might get to d2
but what I like more evenness this move
now a Quincy 3 as now he had does not
have 93 available it looks very
dominating but after this move I need to
go back and then it's a repetition
so maybe I need to do this after all you
cannot take of course as the sangs jack
and my idea is to invite you or possibly
if it should be three but giving up
winning an exchange in that way it's not
so desirable a gap this is probably
better I mean this it's still good for
plaque but hmm it's not really it's not
really okay
yeah well the computer says miss
merciless it wants to take here now yeah
the little tactical things are important
this is a move I I didn't consider at
all because it looks a bit crazy because
of that one but this is not playable at
all technically this is very easy and
this is plants are not difficult once
you have the position on the board
this means that he must take with this
and then just drew a chair King age
eight and her here this stuff leads to a
deadly attack on the G fire it's pretty
clear once you have it on the board
okay I took it and this gives us a large
portion of my advantage
it's a he just he's crammed that has a
bad night yawn c1 and now he exchanged
my excellent light for the back for the
bad one here I mean it's still somewhat
better for black but not not really
not really a big advantage like it was
before yeah and here yeah I think I'm
better really it's this is not leading
to much and at the end he has the bad
bishop I have a protected person and
this is potentially weak
yeah and now I get to get my pieces into
play
yeah I think this is better for black
again right awesome I probably never
really spoiled it completely but I had a
much better much better but much better
ways to play like the capture this was
was much stronger here this one yeah
this has helped white I mean I'm not
quite sure if he is able to to equalize
completely and probably not but still
and it was it wasn't wasn't great no
justing some some computer moves are
really fascinating it wants to play e5
here which I never thought about it just
looks a bit weird to to play that but
maybe this isn't this is okay I mean if
I if I get to h6 with my bishop it's
it's okay something like that I have f6
yeah okay an interesting movie v the
point is if he goes f6 and I go here
he's not able to block gia and cannot go
age 45
I can always enter with with my bishop
but I still okay let's let's say that
that one yeah for example this is the
computer gives black pretty pretty clear
edge here and this is not so so easy to
play it's um it's not like in the game
where ever protected pass on d4 and I
don't really see I can go if I they for
maybe
yeah I still e5 as a nurse and
interesting news as well okay a
complicated game I hope you enjoyed it
and thanks for watching